Janis excuse-moi tu sais où je peux
avoir une sangle
ouais 135
malgré son handicap rien n'est
impossible pour Ben Kader ce plaisir roi
de 26 ans fait de l'équitation depuis
deux ans aux écuries du château
déficient visuels à 80%, le jeune homme
a dû renoncer à son métier de militaire
dans la cavalerie venir au centre
équestre lui permet de se ressourcer
lorsque je suis à cheval je me base pas
du tout sur sur ma vue mais vraiment sur
mon ressenti et
ça me permet d'oublier en quelque sorte
mon handicap dans le sens où ça me
permet de m'évader le cavalier brosse
cure les pieds et applique des soins à
son cheval nommé exotique de manière
autonome ces moments permettent de
gagner la confiance de l'animal qu'il
côtoie depuis quelques semaines
seulement ça lui fait du bien donc j'en
profite et c'est un moment détente qu'on
partage tous les deux
donc il se fait beau je le fais beau mon
but en tout cas c'est d'avoir une
équitation une équitation classique
comme comme une personne voyante et
évoluer comme une personne voyante et
être autonome à 100% je le dis je serai
pas possible mais un maximum d'autonomie
une fois sur la selle direction la
carrière pendant ses entraînements ben
Kader travaille sur les différentes
allures du cheval et pratique les sauts
d'obstacles son instructeur Raoul vient
l'assister grâce à des boîtiers appelés
si coach un système permettant aux deux
hommes de communiquer à distance plus à
droite et maintenant pression de jambes
à droite à droite à droite en équilibre
là tu étais complètement en biais je me
suis rendu compte que sa progression en
fait elle allait beaucoup plus vite que
sur un cavalier normal parce qu'on
équitation la vue est un ennemi au début
parce que les yeux prennent le relais
sur la les parties du corps qui sont
censées en fin de compte fonctionner par
sensation je pense que depuis qu'on a
commencé à travailler ensemble avec ben
je crois que le moins le moins possible
ça a été complètement banni de notre
vocabulaire ben Kader compte poursuivre
le développement de ces techniques
équestres si son niveau le permet il
envisage même de participer ces
prochaines années à des concours
hippiques